October 2015 the GOI 1 imaging satellite
passes high above western China it
captures a disturbing image the ground
below is covered with large blood-red
scars not sure what this huh these red
marks no they don't look good at all
looks to me like the ground is bleeding
the arid landscape in the image is in
the shinjang province at the edge of
China's Taklamakan desert zooming in
further on the image reveals that the
red patches are divided into distinct
rows ground level investigation finally
reveals the answer to the mystery and
it's red hot the region is famous for
its hot peppers and chilies Gingin
cuisine is very spicy it's very hot the
Roe's seen in the image are millions of
chillies drying out in the hot desert
air throughout the fall the hillsides of
Xinjiang become bright red as the
chilies are laid out to dry
Chili's are not indigenous to China but
for the last 300 years or so they have
been increasingly used as an ingredient
in all sorts of cuisines to add flavor
and spice and the demand for them is
extremely high the chilies are deaf to
dry in the Sun preferably at
temperatures around 90 degrees which is
certainly what the temperature is out in
that part of scenes young that's a whole
lot of chilies so what the satellite
image is actually showing us is that
China's national tastes now can be seen
from space